Thank you all for being here.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliff.
I'm the manager of the
Student Arts programs at MIT.
And we're all here today to
kick off the 2020/2021 15K
Creative Arts Competition.
We'll have a series
of workshops,
a really thorough application
session with some feedback,
one-on-one mentoring.
And lots of things like pitch
critiques to help everybody,
no matter where they
are with their venture
to enable them to succeed.
So I'm really excited
to kick things off.
So without further
ado, I'm going
to introduce Wendy Swart
Grossman and Jen Guillemin
from Creative Re/Frame.
Hello, MIT.
We're so happy to be here.
I am Jen Guillemin.
And I am Wendy Swart Grossman.
And we are so honored to be
with you today here at MIT.
And I want to
start with a story.
About the first
entrepreneur I ever met.
Who trusted his
instincts, took on risk,
invested in his employees, and
challenged conventional wisdom
with humor and brilliance.
It was my brother.
The summer my brother,
Martin, was nine years old,
he had a crazy
successful lemonade stand
in front of our house.
He made so much
money, it kept him
in candy bars and comic books
throughout the long winter.
And based on this
early success at nine,
the next summer, when he
turned 10, he expanded.
His franchised his
lemonade stands.
And he had three of them around
the neighborhood that were
run by his trusted buddies.
And when he was 11, he branched
out to the local beach.
And he would sell
cans of ice-cold sodas
to the sunbathers for
a 50% markup per can.
He was so successful,
he was shut down
by the park and rec police.
Because he didn't have
a peddler's license.
But he didn't just go away.
Not my brother, man.
He set up his wagon,
full of coolers,
on the far side of
the street and had
his staff of middle schoolers
fan the beach, taking orders.
Yeah.
Martin delivered.
He was a brilliant man, but
not in a conventional way.
In fact, he barely
graduated from high school.
Because he was too
busy with the company
that he started at age 16.
He had one of these
curious nimble minds,
and he was hungry.
And he saw a hole in the market.
And the floor cleaning
business that he started
grew to be the largest
floor cleaning, buffing,
and waxing company in Southern
California, called Floor Tech.
He had a fleet of trucks and
hundreds of crew members,
making him a millionaire
by the time he was 26.
There are so many ways to
be creative in starting
your business, your own venture.
And just as many
reasons why people
feel compelled to put
something new in the world.
For my brother, he loved money.
The more, the better.
In fact, he would
iron his dollar bills
in order to fit more of
them into his wallet.
To him, it was a
fascinating game.
He also loved creating
networks and talking
to people, similar to myself,
and giving his employees
opportunities to change
their lot in life
by offering them real wages.
And I'm an entrepreneur myself,
but my bottom line isn't money.
I'm motivated by how many
people I can touch, and help,
and organize.
My return on investment is
measured, not only by profit,
but on the social return
on investment, known
as the triple bottom line.
Yes, profit.
But people and planet, as well.
While my brother was
busy making his millions,
I was a political organizer.
Tapping into my super
power of connection
by working on
presidential campaigns.
And then pivoting
to non-profits.
And now I am both an educator,
and co-founder with Jen,
of a creative
consulting startup.
I needed to trust
what motivated me.
But enough about me.
Enough about my brother.
What we're here for
is to talk about you.
What is important
here, is understanding
and tapping into what it
is that motivates you.
Where do you have,
and where do you
find what Jen and I have
coined as your CIIP.
Your care.
What do you care about?
What issue is it
that interests you?
What ideas do you have?
And where is your passion?
Because the more you
understand and trust
your motivation for
doing what you do,
the more authentic, the
more connected, and the more
meaningful your work becomes.
And this is what the 15K
Creative Arts Competition here
at MIT is really all about.
It's about giving you the
tools and the incentives
you need to start your
own creative venture.
We know that the best
ventures are those that solve,
not only real problems, but
are attached to a passion
that you, as the founder, holds.
When I moved to Boston
in the mid '90s,
I went to a
community arts event.
And I met a person who
changed the course of my life.
His name was Sidewalk Sam.
And he was an artist, a
provocateur, a visionary,
and the first creative
entrepreneur I ever met.
If you were living in
Boston in the mid '90s,
you would know exactly the
person that I'm talking about.
Sidewalk Sam was
trained as an artist
and wanted to make his
living being an artist.
He started out as a, kind
of in a traditional way,
of having a studio and
working with galleries.
But that didn't work for him.
He wanted something else.
So he carved out his own unique
niche as a street artist.
He began using chalk to draw
replicas of famous masterpieces
on the sidewalks
throughout Boston.
And as his fame grew,
so did his client base
and corporate sponsors.
The streets of Boston
became his Canvas.
In 1995, five years before I
met him, the mayor of Boston
was trying to figure out how to
celebrate the 20th anniversary
of Earth Day.
Sidewalk Sam made a proposal.
He said, I know, I have an idea.
Let's shut down the streets--
a major thoroughfare,
[INAUDIBLE] Drive in Boston.
Paint it with
biodegradable paint,
and invite all the people
of Boston to come out
and draw flowers, and
trees, and butterflies.
Turning a highway
into an urban meadow.
When they looked at him
like he was crazy and asked
how he thought they
might pay for this,
he was two steps ahead of them.
He had already secured Dunkin'
Donuts as a corporate sponsor.
Thousands of people came
out to the streets that day
and drew pictures
on Storrow Drive.
The genius of Sidewalk
Sam was his ability
to leverage the transformative
power of the arts
to create community
in partnership
with local businesses.
His sponsors achieved their
strategic business objectives
while supporting Sidewalks Sam.
And he was able to achieve
his mission of bringing art
to the people.
I should mention, as
a bit of a disclaimer,
that I spent a lot of time with
Sidewalk Sam over the years
because I ended up marrying
his son in the late '90s.
And together, we volunteered
at hundreds of events
over the course of two decades.
Throughout his career,
Sidewalk Sam's and events
became more and more
participatory in nature.
As he espoused the belief
that everyone is an artist.
To him, the arts weren't
rarefied and only
for the elite.
The arts were alive, and they
were for all of us to share.
At one festival in
downtown Boston,
I volunteered to hand out chalk.
A man was walking past,
and he reluctantly
agreed to take a piece of
chalk and draw on the sidewalk.
However, when he
started drawing,
his whole demeanor changed.
Usually people draw
for maybe five minutes.
He ended up staying and
drawing for a full hour.
And when he returned
the chalk to me,
he had tears in his eyes.
He explained to me that
he worked his whole life
in insurance.
And he loved to draw as a
kid, and he only that day
remembered how
much he missed it.
Something opened
up in him that day.
And that was the
magic of Sidewalk Sam.
And his form of
entrepreneurship was
to create environments that
change hearts and minds.
Sidewalk Sam made his
living doing what he loved,
which is not easy in the arts,
and his return on investment
was collective joy.
He changed lives by
helping people unlock
their personal creativity.
And he certainly influenced me.
Because I became
an entrepreneur,
working within a University
to create programs and courses
for art students.
So they, too, could find ways to
unlock their creative purpose.
Whether you relate
more to Martin,
the millionaire story,
or Sidewalk Sam's model
of the importance of putting
something out in the world
that taps into connection
and creativity.
It really doesn't matter.
Because they're both
incredibly important,
and they're both equally valid.
There is room at the table for
all the reasons people show up.
And are motivated to create.
And there really is no better
place to explore this than MIT.
Math, science, technology,
but also arts resources.
Like the one that this very
15K Creative Arts Competition
represents.
Through the arts
at MIT programming.
What Jen and I have found,
from working in the innovation
and entrepreneurship
spaces, is the importance
of this type of
cross-disciplinary thinking.
This all starts with having
that diversity of ideas.
And the skill-sets
to get it out there.
So while, right now, you may
just have a hint of an idea,
it's crucial to say it aloud.
And to talk with
others about it.
And to think broadly
about what skills
will be needed to put this idea
that's hatching into action.
Take an inventory
of yourself and be
incredibly honest of the skills
you come to the table with.
And what it is you need,
that you don't have.
Then, finding others
that share your big goal.
Your big dream.
But come at it from really
different entry points,
as this will only make
your finished project
that much better.
For example, Jen and I have
crazy different backgrounds.
So Jen has this incredibly rich
career in both higher education
and the arts world.
And I come from a political
background, as I mentioned.
But together, we
started a company.
But we also knew that we
needed help from other folks.
So we reached out to the
Small Business Development
Administration in
downtown Boston.
And met with their volunteer
teams of lawyers and business
advisors.
And then we hired a designer to
get our website up and running.
And now, we employ
other incredible people
who help us with the pieces
that they love and are really
good at, including
social media, database
management, and marketing.
So as you're thinking
about your venture that
might be brewing in
the back of your head,
think about what makes for
a powerful combination.
What are your superpowers?
And be honest.
And who can help fill in the
holes with their superpowers.
But we need to get real.
We need to really
talk and address
the elephant in the room
and, unfortunately, it's
more like a whole
herd of elephants.
We are nine days away from
the most important election
in a hundred or more years.
220,000 people have died in
the US alone from Covid-19.
And over one million have
died across our shared planet.
Disparity between the haves
and the have-nots is huge.
And unfortunately, it's growing.
And, of course, this
is all playing out
with the backdrop of a
world that is on fire.
Other than that, Mrs. Lincoln,
how did you enjoy the play?
It's nutty.
But we're to tell you
that there is hope.
And there is inspiration.
And what we are finding is that
creativity is alive and well.
Human beings are programmed
to be in community, to live,
to inspire, to pivot and grow.
And this provides all of
us with the incredible hope
and inspiration we all need
to get ourselves out of bed.
We, as a nation, are
turning to the arts.
And to creative problem-solvers
as our salve, our balm,
our hope.
One of the projects that Jen and
I work on at Creative Re/Frame
is called "100 Conversations."
Launched in the summer
of 2019, the two of us
would jump on our bikes
and tool around Boston,
meeting with individual,
inspirational creative
practitioners, artists,
and thought leaders
in order to help build
a culture of creativity
around their shared stories.
Making connections and
building community.
This, of course, is now
morphed into socially distanced
conversations and Zoom calls.
And we are documenting how
these same incredible arts
leaders are pivoting, thinking
broader, and be, in many ways,
even more impactful.
One of these conversations
was with the Arts
at MIT's very own Shannon Rose.
Who, in addition to adding
her brilliance to MIT,
she's a singer, and the
co-founder of Festina.
Bringing gorgeous,
uplifting church music
to congregations
across New England.
Thanks to COVID, they have
pivoted to a unique niche
and have had thousands
of hits for a piece
they have done set in
the CDC COVID Guidelines
to Liturgical Music.
Check out the chat
box for the link.
In addition to Festina,
we've had conversations
with arts administrators,
entrepreneurs, muralists,
and musicians.
And while our current
situation is less than ideal,
to paraphrase Toni Morrison,
"This is precisely the time
that creatives go to work."
There's no time for despair.
No time for self-pity.
No need for silence.
No room for fear.
We speak, we write,
we do language.
That is how civilizations heal.
For 10 years, Wendy
and I have been
teaching courses on
cultural entrepreneurship
and the creative economy to
millennials and Gen Z students.
Initially, our goal was
to provide our students
with basic business skills to
help them build sustainable
careers in the arts.
But what we found
was that students
from across the University,
business, computer science,
even engineering, were signing
up for our classes too.
Even if they didn't
plan on going
into the creative professions,
they were drawn to the class.
And we wondered why.
What we learned,
that these students
craved opportunities
to be creative,
and to work across disciplines.
And think of new ways that
they can both make money
while doing something that
was meaningful to them.
We were teaching
something they were not
getting in some of
their other courses,
reminding us once again that
arts and creativity are really
inherent to what it
means to be human.
Our class helps students
create and launch
ventures that reside at
the intersection of arts
and culture, business and
technology, and social impact.
And we know that your
generation has the capacity
to re-imagine better
jobs of the future.
And what better place to
explore this convergence
of arts and technology,
than right here at MIT.
At Creative Re/Frame,
we have a saying.
And it goes like this,
"Make like an artist.
Care like an activist.
Strategize like an entrepreneur.
And implement like
an organizer."
So as you begin your journey
in the 15K Creative Arts
Competition, we leave you
with four key takeaways.
Make.
Trust your creative vision.
Don't be afraid to
think differently.
Invite disruption.
Find a need, and think
about your unique approach
to meeting that need.
Think about your CIIP.
As Wendy mentioned earlier,
your care, idea, issue, passion.
Because it is your
CIIP, that is your fuel.
It is what will help you get
through sleepless nights,
rejection, and the
grueling work that
comes hand-in-hand with
creating a startup.
For Martin, he knew exactly what
people wanted on that hot beach
during the summer.
For Sidewalk Sam, he recognized
the need for creativity
in everyday life.
At Creative Re/Frame, we
care about integrating
arts and innovation spaces.
What is your creative vision.
Care.
Get other people excited.
And get other people to
care about your vision.
Find others who want
to share your passion,
and build your team.
People are attracted to
purpose and a clear vision.
The research shows that most
people find meaning and purpose
when they are part of something
bigger than themselves.
So, with that in mind,
how might your venture
consider the triple bottom line.
People, planet, and profit.
By attaching yourself
to a greater purpose,
people are more
likely to join you
in implementing that vision.
Whether it was Martin's
team of helpers combing
that beach or Sidewalk Sam's
participants, who rediscovered
art after many years.
These are the things that you
could be doing when you're
CIIP is steeped in meaning.
You can find and
build ventures that
not only help other
people's lives,
but also offer you
deep satisfaction.
Strategize.
Seek and build excellence.
Build operational
excellence around your idea.
Put together a solid business
model that you feel proud of
and that meets a need.
Addressing not only the
return on the investment,
but also the social
return on investment.
And finally, implement.
Use the vast resources
that are available
right here at MIT,
and across Boston.
There will be workshops
and programs designed
to help you build and
amplify your venture
so you can bring your creative
vision into the spotlight.
Take advantage of all of it.
As you will carry
these skills with you
for the rest of your life.
Throughout the
entire process, we
remind you to
remember the values
of thinking like an artist.
Remember the power of
improvisation, empathy,
social imagination,
and resourcefulness.
In her book, "The
Culture of Possibility,"
Arlene Goldbard writes,
"We need to learn
to see like the most
committed and skilled artists.
Eyes wide open, taking it all
in, turning away from nothing.
Cultivating empathy
and imagination.
Taking risks admitting
mistakes and persevering."
In essence, my friends, the
arts and entrepreneurship
are really not that different.
Both rely on storytelling to
express compelling narratives.
Both are about taking
risks and making mistakes
and persevering.
Whatever your
entrepreneurial journey is,
and whatever story
got you here today,
we are here to say
yes, go for it.
You've got this.
There is so much hope and
potential and opportunity
at the intersection of
arts and technology.
And the 15K Creative
Arts Competition
is the perfect
launching pad for you.
We commend you as you
set forth on your journey
and we look forward
to seeing the seeds
that you plant today, and
see how they grow over
the course of the months ahead.
Your work will
help to re-imagine
the jobs, the products, and
the services of the future.
Thank you for joining us.
And thank you Arts
at MIT for inviting
Creative Re/Frame to help
launch the 15K Creative Arts
Competition.
Thank you both so much.
That was fantastic.
Also your technology
is so impressive.
This is the best Zoom that
I've seen in eight months.
Round of applause
for the technician
behind the kitchen table!
Beautifully done, everybody.
So that was full of some
really fantastic insights.
And a lot of motivation.
I'm curious to know if anybody
has any questions for Wendy
and Jen.
Or if Wendy and Jen have
any questions for others.
They sort of like to turn
these things upside down,
so we're going to do
a 360 conversation
before we take our break.
Well we would like to invite
some of the people here
today to share your
creative vision with us,
if we have anybody.
Jen and I have been working
in this field for a long time.
And working with students
just like all of you
to help you take these little
ideas, and help them launch.
And we're so curious who's
out there in the Zoom-verse
to see how we can help you
as you move through it all.
Anything bubbling out there?
I'll also comment that, if
you need a little time to sort
of marinate on everything
that we just discussed,
our third session
will also include
sort of the opportunity
for conversation
with really wonderfully
established entrepreneurs
and educators.
I know that we have
some people in here who
are studying entrepreneurship.
So I'd be curious to see
what the takeaways were,
or what's excited
you about this.
And we're kind of open books.
I'll talk about anything.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
Yeah, whatever.
Let's see.
I mean this was all
really motivating,
and I've got a question.
It can all seem sort
of like scaling Everest
when you finally got
these great ideas,
and you finally got
all of this energy.
It's an awfully
big uphill climb.
So what are the smallest, or
sort of most important steps,
that you would say
will help people
to catalyze their success.
So what I usually do, is
it's all about ripping off
your blinders.
Going through the world and
starting to be, what I call,
as being awake and aware.
Paying attention to what's
working, what's not working.
Where is there like an
interesting hole in the market?
What do you like to do?
So it really kind of depends.
Sometimes you start
with a problem.
Sometimes you
start with an idea.
Sometimes you start
because you're excited.
And sometimes you start
because you're pissed off.
There's so many different
fabulous organizations
that have been popping
up that are student led.
That was because they realized
that the world was on fire
and who's going to start.
So it's really kind
of paying attention
to both sides of the coin.
And really, it starts
with that whole inventory
of what skills do I have.
What am I good at.
Also paying attention
too to oh, I like this.
I want more of this.
What is this for you.
Anything to add?
I think you I think did
a good job covering.
I think, also,
there are people who
have these crossover interests
that are really interesting.
And I think at a
place like MIT, that
is something that you'll see.
So you'll have somebody who has
this background in engineering,
but they're also really
passionate about music.
And so to think about what's
happening at that intersection,
and what might you bring to it
that is so unique about you.
Because you have
these two interests
that collide in really
interesting ways.
So I think to be
really aware of that.
We think of the
arts as something
that can just be a source
of inspiration internally,
but it also could be part
of your business idea.
And that could launch
you into a new direction.
And what we love is that
whole cross-disciplinary mess.
And sometimes, if we
were together in person,
we would be all be wearing name
tags with different colored
dots on them.
One would be red, "I have
an idea, ask me about it."
Another one would
be blue, saying,
"I've got a lot of cool skills
and I want to help you."
So it's like finding
those other people.
Sometimes we do
have the idea and we
don't know what to do next.
Sometimes we want to
work with somebody else,
but we don't have the idea.
So that's the trick, is being
able to find each other.
Because you don't want to do
it alone, because that's like
boring and lonely.
Those are all really these
are excellent points.
Especially about the
necessity of team building
in partnership.
Yeah, definitely and we had
a question based on that.
So thinking about those
kind of key partnerships.
How do you know when you're
ready for a partnership?
And how do you go about finding
those kind of key partners?
You're ready for a partnership.
You always want a partner.
Don't do it alone.
That's a big red flag.
I'm like, oh I've
got this great idea.
I'm going to do
it all by myself.
And I'm like, oh, cringe,
cringe, cringe, cringe.
No.
You always need help.
And so that was the first part.
What was the second
part of the question.
I don't know.
I just got excited about
finding somebody to work with.
Well I really like
your question.
Because I think it happens
in a lot of different ways.
Sometimes people really
unite over shared interest.
Sometimes you just have
chemistry with somebody.
And then you're like, how
can we do something together.
So as just a little back story,
when Wendy and I first met,
we didn't really
know each other.
And we just went
out for a drink.
And we started talking.
I was asked to propose a course.
And because I had such a
great conversation with Wendy,
I was like I want to co-teach.
I bet we'd be really good
co-teaching together.
And so we started that.
And so it was just
because we had a great--
we had--
We like to play together.
We try to figure out other
ways that we can play.
And I want to be fun to teach.
Because I'm really a
frustrated stand up comic.
And I thought, then
you have people
who have to come to your class.
And then that's like, ooh,
a mandatory [INAUDIBLE]..
And I was like, how cool.
But I had never
really talked before.
And I had done workshops
or whatever, but never
a full-on course.
And I wasn't afraid to say yes.
I'm like, oh, propose a
University course to be you?
Because that's where we started.
And that's like
holding your breath.
Holding your breath
and saying, "Yeah, I'll
do that, even though I've
never done it before."
Write a syllabus?
How the heck do you do that?
And you do a lot of what's
called, well in the art
world, it's called inspiration.
But between you and I, we
just steal each other's stuff,
right.
We steal it, but
then we remake it.
We are inspired.
But you take other
people's stuff,
and then you remake
it in a way that
makes a lot more sense
for your audience.
But you got to start somewhere.
Start with some
kind of a framework.
And that's OK.
You can do that.
All right.
That's legal.
That is legal.
That is OK and encouraged.
I'm really delighted with this.
I want to congratulate you
both for your successes.
And thank you so much
for your generosity
in sharing your insights.